[Music]
so our first Hillary campaign ad was
called everything from awful to sexist
now you're telling me this one here is
none of those things that's correct sir
well let's just take a look I can't see
how it could possibly be any worse left
just like the last time around
Republicans are gonna fry Mitt Romney
and Ben Carson down Twitter stop you're
going down you think that you were
riding in Billy Joel's car I swear
because you're gonna see shattered glass
it's all by now Ghana the golden record
make you all the road along gonna bring
along
Oh Bill Clinton and
shut my mouth slap your grandmom you
think she's gonna lose in there
primaries you sooner see how Sharpton
promptly violence quarter lays out
talking Arkansas law God all you don't
see how this could be viewed as awful or
sexist I'll see it somehow I'm a
crusader can label you a hater while I
say nominate anybody
we're the babymaker oh I see it now oh
dear God
come talking Arkansas but now God
bring a long haul and I'm late shut my
mouth slap your grandmom